نعم نشوان تدخل الحرب على قطاع غزه اليوم
تحديدا شهرا جديدا وهو الشهر الخامس وتبدا
معه بكل تاكيد فصلا او يبدا معه فصلا
جديدا من فصول المعاناه التي يعيشها
الفلسطينيون هنا في قطاع غزه وما زال
العدوان على حاله وحده العمليه العسكريه
على حالها سواء برا وكذلك جوا هنا في
القطاع وبالتحديد في المنطقه الجنوبيه من
قطاع غزه خان يونس التي ما تزال في عين
عاصفه هذه الحرب حيث تستمر الغارات الجويه
المكثفه وتستمر العمليه العسكريه
الاسرائيليه في مناطق عده في خان يونس في
الساعات الماضيه كانت هناك سلسله من
الغارات الجويه العنيفه المركزه التي طالت
حي المناره ومنطقه حي السلام ومحيط المشفى
الاوروبي وادى ذلك الى ارتقاء فلسطيني
واصابه عدد اخر وصلوا المشفى الاوروبي
احدى هذه الغارات الحقت اضرارا ماديه
كبيره في اسقف المشفى الاوروبي الواقع
شرقي خان يونس فضلا عن ذلك
كانت هناك سقوط لبعض الشظايا على خيام
النازحين في هذا المشفى الى جانب ذلك دوت
انفجارات كبيره بفعل هذه الغارات التي
كانت في مناطق ملاصقه تماما الى مدينه رفح
الواقع في المنطقه الجنوبيه من قطع غزه
بالمناسبه ايضا مدينه رفح شهدت سلسله من
الغارات الجويه ربما الاعنف في الساعات
الاخيره كانت ولو قرنت بالاسابيع المنصرمه
تصنف بانها الاعلى من ناحيه الكثافه وكذلك
اعداد الضحايا في هذه الغارات كانت اخر
هذه الغار على ارض تاوي نازحين بالقرب من
معبر رفح البري جنوب شرق مدينه رفح اد ادت
هذه الغاره الى استشهاد طفلتين واصابت نحو
10 اخرين والحاق اضرار ماديه كبيره في هذه
الغاره سبق هذا القصف غارات مماثله طالت
هذه او محيط هذه المنطقه وايضا شقه سكنيه
في حي الجنينه ادى ذلك الى استشهاد طفل
نازح واصابه عدد من افراد اسرته وفي ساعات
الصباح يوم امس كانت هناك سلسله من
الغارات طالت منزلين في منطقه حي الجنينه
وادى ذلك الى استشهاد نحو 25 فلسطينيا على
الاقل في هذه الغارات بعضهم من النازحين
بطبيعه الحال قبل قليل ايضا كانت هناك
غاره في مدينه دير البلح وسبق ذلك غاره
اخرى في مخيم النصيرات الغربي وفي مخيم
نصيرات الشرق ايضا غاره اخرى ووصلت مشفى
العوده في المنطقه الوسطى سته من الاصابات
على الاقل حسب معلومات اوليه حتى هذه
اللحظه لم تعرف طبيعه الغاره التي كانت
قبل قليل في مدينه دير الب لح وسط قطاع
غزه وبالتوازي مع ذلك تسمع اصوات
للاشتباكات ومحركات الاليات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه في مناطق عده في وسط مدينه
غزه وفي المنطقه الغربيه علما بان الاليات
قد عادت نشوان قبل عده ايام للتوغل في هذه
المحاور وسط اشتباكات عنيفه مع المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وقصاد فعي مكثفا طال مناطق عده
شمالي غربي مدينه غزه وجنوبي غربي مدينه
غزه وفي المنطقه الوسطى من مدينه غزه
بالتحديد في حي الرمال وفي محيط مجمع
انصار الحكومه و هناك نسف لعدد من المنازل
السكنيه وفي ساعات النهار وصلت تسعه من
الشهداء الى المشفى المعمداني الى جانب
عدد من المصابين نقلوا الى مجمع الشفاء
الطبي في مدينه غزه يصف السكان هناك
الاشتباكات بانها ربما الاعنف منذ عده
اسابيع علما بان اسرائيل نشوان قالت في
وقت سابق بانها سيطرت تماما وقد قامت
بتفكيك لواء غزه واليوم يعود القتال بشكل
اشد وهذا مخالف تماما ويعكس الروايه
الاسرائيليه التي كانت تتحدث طله الفتره
الماضيه بان قامت بتفكيك لواء غزه وتدميره
وتفكيك البنى التحتيه للمقاومه الفلسطينيه
لكن اليوم نشهد بيانات منفصله سواء للقسام
لسريا القدس لكتاب المجاهدين حتى ابو علي
مصطفى وكتاب المقاومه الوطنيه وكتاب شهداء
الاقصى تقول في هذه البيانات انها نفذت
عمليات قنص واسقاط لمسيرات واستهداف
مركبات عسكريه اسرائيليه ودبابات وترفق
ذلك بمقاطع مصوره توثق هذه العمليات وشده
القصف الاسرائيلي وعوده وتمركز الدبابات
في هذه المناطق يؤكد حتميه وجود هذه
المقاومه الشرسه في هذه المناطق وان
المقاومه لم تتفكك ولم تنتهي في مناطق
يفترض ان اسرائيل قد دمرتها منذ بدء الحرب
على قطاع غزه في ال 27 من اكتوبر الماضي
وهي مناطق تل الهواء ومنطقه الرمال والنصر
في ساعات نهار ايضا يوم امس كانت هناك عده
عمليات قنص قرب مفترق الصرايا والصبره
والثلاثيني ومفترق النصر وتلك العمليات
كانت عبر مسيرات تتبع لقوات الجيش
الاسرائيلي المتوغلة
مدينه غزه في منطقه الشمال لم يكن هذا ال
او هذه المنطقه بمعزل عن اطلاق النار
والقصف المدفعي من قبل القوات الاسريه
التي اطلقت قذائف مدفعيه في منطقه بيت
لاهيا ومنطقه جب جباليه لكنها لم توقع
عصابات بحسب الطواقم الطبيه الفلسطينيه